hi i'm alicia and today i'll be talking
to you about how to apply best practices
of rest apis to graphql
is an open source data query and
manipulation language for apis
and a runtime for fulfilling queries
with existing data
it's a new way to think about apis with
graphql
you can send queries to get exactly the
data you're looking for
in one request graphql can enable
front and back end teams to collaborate
more smoothly when developing
applications
let's look at an example of a graphql
query
here we are querying for user data with
the id of the user
the first thing to note about the query
and the response is that they are
identical
this is because graphql is typed meaning
that what you ask for is what you get
back
we are simply just saying get me the
user with this id
and return me back their name posts and
followers
now let's compare this to how we would
get the same results
using a rest endpoint here we have had
to define three separate endpoints in
order to have the ability to access the
same data
now some of you might say that you could
reduce this now to just one endpoint by
returning the entire user object in the
first request
this would be seen as over fetching of
data one key difference to note here is
that with graphql you know which objects
and data you have available with each
query
so you can specify the shape of the data
you would like back from the server
with rest you can't really define what
is returned to you
as the server decides this so we can
think of graphql as a single endpoint
upon which we have a set of executable
queries that map to a schema of the data
there are three key benefits of using
this approach
first of all all data exchange is
performed at a single endpoint
that means granularity for data load
execution of requests in parallel
and query planning it also means if one
resolver fails the rest of the query can
still resolve and return useful data
secondly the real strength is in the
query language
you can declare which schemas you want
the data from and the format of that
data
which prevents over fetching and under
fetching of data
and thirdly availability of native
integration with the react.js ui
framework and
other client libraries considerably
increases productivity for developers
graphql is great but how does it compare
to rest
there are a number of differences
between the two and all highlight four
of these
when we compare the endpoints russ makes
many smaller requests to many endpoints
and the url taxonomy is used as a
logical api resource manager
graphql on the other hand makes requests
to one endpoint which results in longer
and larger queries for customer data
rest uses http verbs and generally uses
json.xml in order to exchange that data
graphql uses post most of the time and
also leverages different query types
specified inside the protocol not in
http
even though graphql uses a custom query
language on the request
json is returned as a result
when we compare documentation we'll see
that rest uses open api specifications
while graphql
uses a schema generated documentation
frequently we see customers using
graphical or graphql playground to
interact with schema-based graphql
endpoints from a discovery perspective
the portal offers a veritable playground
for developers to try out apis before
they use them in their code
while graphql comes with a built-in
playground that enables users to explore
new queries on the fly including
automatic tab completion
while the two solutions are very
different there are a number of best
practices and rest apis that can be
applied to graphql
let's quickly look at these best
practices
consistency in graphql starts with
well-formed graphql
and we can apply the best practices of
well-formed rest here
here's an example you would never expect
a well-formed rest query to be a list of
employees by department
rather a well-formed rest query would be
a resource
a graph hierarchy is fundamentally a
data-driven hierarchy
it is not a functional hierarchy like an
object model
we should not be treating graphql like
java functions in other words
be data oriented not function oriented
the second best practice is around
submitting and retrieving data
those are not always mirrored operations
in rest
we frequently submit and receive data
from different urls
in particular when retrieving data from
multiple services in a microservice
architecture
command query responsibility segregation
cqrs is common
as we think about how this applies to
graphql we need to consider that query
mutations can get
very complex very quickly especially
with many different types when
submitting very little data
applying cqrs to graphql can help us
avoid this challenge
third is optimizing for reusability and
rest we think a lot about our url
taxonomy
pagination and filtering because
developers can then predict what the
behavior will be of any api they call
in graphql we should be doing the same
thing
with graphql it is important to be
careful with schema stitching because to
the developer
the representation looks like one big
graph but the behavior
of the json returned might be different
so relay cursor connections and input
hints should all present uniform
behavior regardless of the portion
of the graph being requested even with
the best practices i mentioned there are
a number of challenges with graphql
deployments
these revolve around authentication and
authorization
for example graphql doesn't solve
authorization and does not support
authorization for schema browsing
graphql doesn't support a standard for
throttling or quotas it does not have a
unified view of analytics which means
expanding the view of apis from simple
metrics to business and operational
impact metrics can be challenging
and it is based on a single endpoint
which means that there are no url
versions and no support for header or
format versioning
an api management solution can help with
managing the challenges of graphql apis
an api management platform gives you
control over and visibility into the
apis that connect
applications and data across cloud or
on-premises
managing your graphql apis with an api
management platform
enables you to easily manage
authentication and authorization
implement throttle leaner quotas view
detailed analytics
and streamlined versioning to learn more
and get started
check out the links in the description
[Music]
below
you